>> Hi, guys.
Thank you so much for coming to today's author
talk.
Today, we have Emily Nagle Green, who is the
president and CEO of the
Yankee group.
And she wrote this great book called "Anywhere",
about global
connectivity and business initiatives that
can really draw a lot of
value from that increased connectivity in
our world.
So please welcome Emily Nagle Green to Google
Boston.
Emily Nagle Green: Thank you.
Thank you.
I don't need this, I think.
But if anybody wants to talk.
Oh, you're going to hold on to that.
Okay, cool.
Hi, Google Boston, and hi, Google anywhere.
My name's Emily Green and I'm delighted to
be here.
I have Steve Vinter of Google Boston, Google
Cambridge to thank for
that.
Steve and I met about a year ago.
We're both on a committee that the governor
of Massachusetts formed to
get technology leaders in the Boston and greater
Massachusetts area to
help create more energy and enthusiasm around
a very vibrant tech
sector in the Massachusetts area.
And Steve has exhibited all the great qualities
I have come to know
about Google as an organization.
And he's also an awesome dodgeball player,
it turns out.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, he hit my husband with a dodgeball but
with incredible accuracy.
So this is an author talk, and I thought maybe
the easiest way to do it
-- I have some experience with this now because
the book's been out for
a few weeks.
I thought I would offer to interview myself
to make it easy for you.
I know this is supposed to be casual, and
it's Friday, we here in
Boston, we have hot chocolate.
So I thought I would interview myself so that
you can just sort of sit
back and enjoy the interview.
And you don't have to do any work, really.
You can eat your croissants and enjoy your
hot chocolate.
Yes, so I'm told.
The chef says it's his specialty.
So the first thing I thought I would start
with was, who am I?
I'm a researcher and Yankee Group is a 40,
4-0, 40-year old research
firm that is based here in Boston but is focused
on the global
revolution in connectivity that is underway.
I'm a former engineer.
I started my life as a software developer,
but it was so long ago that
I would be homeless if I had to go back to
that profession right now.
But I am proud to say that as a software developer,
I spent some time
working in the entertainment industry.
And I am one of the very first generation
of software developers that
can claim movie credits.
Back in the early 80s, I worked on some really
fun movies and TV shows
doing special effects.
But my software development days are long
behind me.
And I'm a researcher and I spent the last
year with other analysts at
Yankee Group and a lot of other experts in
the industry looking at the
changes that are under way in connectivity.
And it was my view that while a lot of us,
including probably everyone
in this room and everybody on the DVR, is
quite fluent with more
immediate issues that are underway in the
communications revolution.
There's a much larger audience for that news
out there in the world
that hasn't yet put some of these changes
into context and doesn't yet
see the tremendous implications that are ahead.
So let's start with the first question on
my interview list after who
am I.
And that is what, in fact, is anywhere?
What definition do I give to that word?
I sort of co-opted that term.
That's what industry analysts do, we either
make up words or we borrow
words and use them for our own purposes.
So apologies for that.
But I think it really works.
Anywhere is the term that I've given to the
emergence of ubiquitous
connectivity, how it will connect all of us
on the planet, and
ultimately -- hi -- all the things that we
care about.
And I call it anywhere because for my money,
it is completely changing
the meaning of location in two kind of interesting
ways that are
contradictory.
In one sense, as the world is connected by
a pervasive, capable,
extremely cool digital fabric, it doesn't
so much matter where we are.
So location becomes less significant, but
the information associated
with location becomes much more significant
and much more useful to us
because it can be embroidered and embedded
in a lot of our activities.
So that's the anywhere revolution and it's
coming about because of what
I call the anywhere network.
That's my vision and the vision of Yankee
Group for a seamless --
hardly at that stage today -- intelligent,
sort of headed in the right
direction; ubiquitous, that is, everywhere;
and abundant network.
We're actually going towards that future.
And in recent years we're accelerating towards
that future even faster
than we might have imagined.
I like the word abundant for network capacity
and I think it's
particularly relevant within the last -- what
is it?
Twenty four hours since the announcement about
Google's ultra-high speed
contribution to the network.
So thanks for that.
I'm a big believer in abundance in the network.
One of the people I interviewed for this book
was Bob Metcalfe, who if
you don't know him, is a seminal thinker and
inventor and leader in the
history of network technology and the phrase
he uses -- which I have
completely stolen -- is squanderable abundance
of the network.
And I think it's when the network is abundant
to a degree that we can
actually waste it, that's when we're struck
with really compelling
ideas for how to take advantage of it in brand
new ways.
And you know, the best, most recent example
of the last few years would
be YouTube, of course.
So why is this important?
Well, it's important for a lot of us in this
room and on this DVR
because it's creating really interesting work
for us and fun work, but
in the larger question, remember I said I
wrote the book for the larger
audience that needs to understand how impactful
this transition towards
a global network with squanderable abundance
is going to be, is that
the changes in this revolution will make it
the largest technology
revolution of all of our lifetimes, even for
those of you who are among
the -- on the younger end in this room as
opposed to on the older
end -- this is going to be a transformation
that will dwarf anything
that we've previously seen.
I like to compare it to the largest tech revolution
that I think we've
all been through in some form or another in
our lifetime so far, and
that's the emergence of the commercial Internet,
which happened
starting in '95 to 2005.
And when you think about that revolution and
how it emerged, the
locations where it was relevant to us was
where we worked or in our homes or at schools,
but not in a lot of other places.
Even so, it brought a billion people together
in the first ten years of
its commercial maturity.
And the value added from an economic perspective
by this brand new
infrastructure that a billion people were
able to use in essentially
three places was in the billions of dollars.
Because it allowed companies and services
and activities to emerge that
could not have existed without the Internet.
Hard for the younger people in this audience
today to even imagine,
right?
And then that's what happens with any kind
of pervasive infrastructure.
Highway systems created the hotel industry
in the 50s.
The maturation of the professional commercial
television industry
created really what's the modern advertising
industry.
Anywhere is a revolution that will connect
not only work, home, and
school but plazas and subways and jungles.
And if you read the story in the New York
Times this morning about
school buses now starting to experiment with
adding mobile routers to
school buses so kids can recapture that lost
productivity of commute
time to and from school with wireless routers.
In the next five years alone, this will mean
that over five billion
people are connected.
And the real thing that's driving that, of
course, is wireless
technology, because wireless networks are
now coming to parts of the
world that would never have seen connectivity
if it was dependent on
running fixed-line networks with telephone
poles and fiberoptic and
copper cables.
So five billion people will be connected,
at the very least, through
mobile phone technology which will be for
many of them the only way
that they actually ever touch this digital
network.
But more importantly, and I'll come back to
this in a moment, we're
going to start connecting things in a really
serious way, and that's
where some of the biggest transformation that's
ahead is.
So as a result of that, the economic value
from this revolution
compared to the emergence of the Internet
in the first ten years, will
be in the trillions of dollars rather than
in the billions of dollars.
And I know that's true because I'm an expert.
You know what an expert is, right?
"X" is the unknown quantity and "spurt" is
a drip under pressure.
So an expert is an unknown drip under pressure.
It's an old joke.
But at Yankee Group, we measure the economic
value of the emergence of
the broadband network infrastructure around
the world, and this is our
forecast most recently of the total value
of revenues in the network,
just providing broadband services to consumers
and businesses.
So by 2013, about a billion dollars in value.
But that's the platform itself.
So if we were talking about the highway system,
that would be revenues
from tolls on the highway.
But when you think about the Googles, the
YouTubes, the Amazons, all
the experiences that we're going to be able
to layer on top with assets
like Android, then we're talking about trillions
of dollars of
incremental value on top of that digital global
platform.
So the book is about the emergence of that.
It is not a tech book at all.
I wrote it for my mother, your aunts and uncles,
your friends who don't
understand what it is you do.
It's about how this transformation is inevitable.
It's really not stoppable.
But there's a lot of explanation about why
that's true.
It's about the consequences of ubiquitous
connectivity.
And it's about the tremendous commercial opportunities
associated with
ubiquitous connectivity.
And it does that through some things that
I hope are friendly and not
intimidating.
As I said, it's not a deep dive into the technology.
I like to tell people I'm a recovering engineer,
you know.
I have a -- belong to a 12-step program.
I have a number I call if I'm tempted to engineer
anything because I'm
not allowed to do it anymore.
So we do support it with a little data, so
that we're credible.
But it does involve a lot of anecdotal explanations
and experience from
over 50 leaders in connectivity.
I'm proud to say, that because I'm part of
a very vibrant community of
technology entrepreneurialism in the Boston
area, that over ten of those
people were based in the Boston area.
People like Bob Metcalfe, Nicholas Negroponte,
Hamish Fraser, who's the
director of tele-medicine at Partners in Health,
one of the
organizations that's doing tremendous work
in Haiti right now.
But beyond that, we created some personas
to make it easy for people to
visualize in five and ten years time how experiences
would be
different.
There's some case studies, there is even some
Cosmo quiz style things
that make it more engaging. So the goal was
to make it very accessible
and fun, but also compelling.
One of the ways in which we do that we tried
to help people to understand how this
revolution is emerging around the world is
by means of something
called the anywhere index.
And very simply put, it's a brute-force instrument
to help people
understand the pace at which broadband that
is emerging around the
world.
We look at the number of broadband lines in
the world, wired or wireless
lines, and we compare that to population in
a region.
And when there are fewer broadband lines than
people, that's one state
of play in the network.
And as broadband lines start to increase beyond
the population in a
region, that's what we call the anywhere tipping
point.
Because the pervasiveness of the cape -- of
a capable network with
squanderable abundance starts to allow innovation
and adoption of
entirely new behaviors and activities.
Um, so this is unfolding before us.
And these are some, some figures that we update
at Yankee Group on a
regular basis.
Right now, to use the terms that I just laid
out, regions that have
more than one broadband line per person -- and
if you think about the
number of things in your life that might ultimately
have broadband
connections, we have very few countries in
the world that actually meet
that definition.
And it's a little bit hard to see here in
Boston today, but you can see
Sweden, and you can see Japan and Korea perhaps,
and Australia are colored as anywhere countries.
>> [inaudible]
Emily Nagle Green: Yes, yes.
Yes.
The bar, you know, full disclosure, the bar
for our wireless broadband line,
the bar is pretty low in our definition, because
we're not really at
the infrastructure and the mobile space that,
you know, 4G broadband,
that's what we would all like to have.
Maybe 6G.
But over the next five years, a number of
countries because of the
build out of wireless networks and upgrades
to 3G as AT&T tries to fix
it's map relative to Verizon, and as countries
around the world pull
more fiber from stimulus packages from government,
we see most of
Western Europe and all of North America in
five years time having a
total number of broadband lines that will
surpass the population.
And it's, I think, a good indicator that we're
accelerating into a very
different environment in the next five to
ten years.
How will it change us as individuals?
That's some of what we talk about in the book
in what I think is an
engaging way, that's some of the feedback
I've had so far.
Just to give you a bit of a taste, a couple
of personas drawn from the
book, you'd learn more about them as when
you read it Fatuma is a
coffee farmer in Kenya.
She has tuberculosis, which is extraordinarily
common in emerging
countries, unfortunately, cause we know how
to cure it.
But at this time a chronic disease that requires
ongoing maintenance
from a health care worker.
She also doesn't have access to information
resources that would tell
her how she could price her coffee beans to
get the best price.
She -- somebody comes up and offers her a
price for her crop and that's
what she sells it for.
And one of the challenges in compiling assets,
economic assets, in
Third World markets is she has no access to
banks.
There are no ATMs and no easy-to-reach banking
resources.
That's her life today.
In India, where wireless networks are already
more common, in
particular in urban areas like Mumbai, we
have Habib who's a street
cart merchant.
He's 15-years old, so he has the basic education
that a lot of lower
middle class Indians get.
He operates a cart but he has to buy his groceries
at retail.
He competes for his space on the sidewalk
every day, so he's worried
about getting the best price for his groceries,
but he's compelled to
pay whatever he has to so that he can get
to his spot on the sidewalk.
He has a lot of tourists come by, but they
haven't changed their money
yet, so he doesn't have a means to do business
with them because they
have dollars or euros and he only deals in
rupees.
And because he has cash, he's a very easy
target for petty thieves.
Finally, in emerging parts of the world, the
state of the network today
allows people like Allen to do a knowledge
worker's job, but what he's
really working with is secondhand data.
He's working with data that has been stale
and processed through many
sources.
And the sources of information he has are
quite siloed.
You see here that he's looking at multiple
screens.
And it's the gray matter between his ears
that's attempting to
integrate the information that's been presented
to him, and it's mostly
text.
The work schedule -- he has to work when the
markets are open and he's
basically chained to this desk.
But as the network becomes more pervasive
around the world and as the
capacity of the network grows and its intelligence
grows, everybody's
experience changes in some way.
For Fatuma, she gets better health care because
organizations like
Partners in Health can develop medical records
systems that depend on
network access.
And so, the community health care workers
in Kenya and in Haiti and
Rwanda can find Fatuma, let her know when
the medications for her
tuberculosis are available, and they can track
where she lives.
She also can get information about market
pricing for her crop on a
mobile phone, and she can do banking through
her mobile phone.
So she's able to build assets and that's a
life-changing set of
opportunities.
And that will move her, in the next ten years,
and people like her into
a burgeoning lower middle class in places
like Kenya, which is just now
being touched by fiberoptic cable undersea.
For Habib, and other citizens like him, he
will be able to use netbooks
and other low cost computing devices that
will be subsidized or
sponsored by a retailer.
And he can order product, and so he pick it
up efficiently without
missing his spot on the street corner.
He can earn points from offering mobile couponing
and mobile banking
services, so that he doesn't have to handle
money, and that reduces his
vulnerability to thieves.
And it's been shown that the introduction
of connected devices like
laptops, actually dramatically raises the
literacy levels of family
members around individuals, and that was something
that come out in
conversations with Negroponte with his one
laptop per child movement.
But in more mature parts of the world that
already have an abundant
network but which is going to continue to
grow in capacity and
intelligence, what we're headed towards is
knowledge workers like Allen
who will be able to use integrated highly
visual displays that follow
him from place to place.
So that he can appear in a new location in
his back porch or in another
venue and work almost in different to his
location.
But he'll be working with real time data because
the abundant global
network will be able to bring censor-based
information to him on crops,
so rather than relying on secondhand informations
about the maturity of
Fatuma's coffee beans, he'll ultimately be
able to understand the
maturity of coffee beans from the field-based
networks themselves.
And he'll be unchained from his desk, and
we'll see a marvelous
flowering -- as we are already starting to
do in the tech sector --
we'll see a marvelous flowering outside of
the tech sector of workers
whose jobs are changing, their connections
to the workplace changing,
so that they may be freed and have less conventional
work hours and
then maybe a less conventional relationship
with their employers.
So I said I was going to interview myself.
I told you who I am.
I told you a little bit about Anywhere, the
emergence of ubiquitous
connectivity; I told you why you should care
because it's the largest
technology revolution of our lifetimes.
I told you a little bit about what that change
in pervasive abundant
intelligent network will help people do.
And I talked a little bit about what we hope
the book will do.
So that means I really only have one question
left which I think I'm
more or less on schedule.
And that is my own initial impression on what
it might mean for
Googlers?
So I thought I'd take a few moments on that
before we maybe talk a
little bit about the book, if you like.
You guys are an interesting group of people
because you have a
fascinating organization.
And this book, frankly, many of you may not
learn much that you don't
already feel you know about the pace at which
the network's evolving
and the capabilities of the network.
Remember, we're talking to a much larger audience
about the evolution
of connectivity.
And this book is an optimistic, encouraging
future vision of the world
that I hope will enroll more believers in
what you're doing.
So hopefully, it will enlarge the appetite
of the world for Google's
incredibly exciting products and expertise.
But I think more than that, I do think Google
is a company that thinks
big, tremendously big.
And that's inspiring, but I think it's fair
to ask given what we saw on
our research about the rate at which the network's
expanding and its
capacities and future intelligence -- the
question might be are you
sure you're thinking big enough?
Because I think not only are we connecting
more people, we're going to
have more connected consumers from a billion
to five or six billion.
But we're going to have new kinds of consumers.
I saw once in a design philosophy statement
about Google user
interfaces or user experiences that you seek
to meet unarticulated
needs, which I liked, because I often talk
about the latent appetites
of consumers.
We are a mobile species.
We were born on our feet.
We learned to walk early on.
And we respond to things that allow us to
be mobile.
And we love the portability of devices and
experiences.
And what I see emerging is a new kind of consumer,
an Anywhere consumer
who has a innate, eventually an innate expectation
that experiences
should be portable.
And you're starting to make that happen, but
I think there are many
more experiences that aren't yet quite as
portable as we might like
them to be.
This Anywhere consumer is an Anywhere worker
as well.
And again, in the tech sector we see it is,
I think, well-established
early signs of new behaviors in relationship
to a workplace.
But over the long term, I think companies
everywhere will be
transformed by the expectations we -- sorry
-- we have as consumers and
employees for state-of-the-art technology
that keeps pace with the
evolution of consumer technologies.
Why should our workplace platforms be any
less sophisticated and easy
to use and fun and flexible as the things
that we can buy for
ourselves?
And that will change companies as we move
proprietary hardware and
software out of big IT operations and move
those things into the
clouds.
I think anywhere enterprises can be become
more nimble and more
exciting and a more contemporary workplace,
virtual workplace, for
employees.
But I just wanted to leave on one final note,
one of the most
interesting things to me personally about
the emergence of ubiquitous
connectivity is the emergence of new kinds
of connected devices.
I do see within the tech sector -- and I have
been in technology for
35 years, I started, I was just a baby when
I started.
But I do see a little bit of myopia from time
to time.
We get so focused on computers, laptops and
phones, what's really
happening is connectivity becomes ubiquitous.
And at the cost of adding connectivity to
things continues to fall,
we're seeing a lot more connected things.
And there's where Google really needs to make
sure it's thinking big.
Maybe you've seen some of these -- these are
all real devices.
This is a connected pill bottle made by a
company here in Cambridge called Vitality.
And when you take the cap off, it can let
your friends, your health
care professionals know if you're taking your
medication.
So it can help maintain a health regimen.
It doesn't do anything else, but it does a
better job of being a pill
bottle because it's connected.
This is also invented by the same guy, David
Rose, this is a connected
umbrella.
It doesn't tell you what the weather is, but
twice a day it can get an
update on the possibility of precipitation
where you are, and it turns
that light on in the bottom of the handle
if it's going to rain.
So it doesn't tell you the weather but it
does a better job of being an
umbrella.
It is more "umbrella-ish" because it knows
when you need it.
You're more likely to have it with you.
This is an active RFID tag, not a very sexy-looking
thing, but the tip
of the iceberg in terms of something that
I think is very sexy, which is
equipping assets and businesses and environments
around the world with
connectivity so they can report on their location,
whether they're wet or dry or broken or complete
or ready or unready or in some sort of danger.
And as that technology becomes more pervasive
in our ambient
environment that world is -- that's going
to flood our world with some
rich data.
And that's part of the opportunity for an
enterprise like Google to
organize that.
This is a Bluetooth ring.
It's a piece of jewelry.
It was just debuted in January at the Consumer
Electronics Show.
It has an E-ink display, so it can accept
little text messages and
things.
And so it can connect to your phone.
And there have been a lot of attempts on connected
clothing and things.
I think there will be many more experimentations
ahead with connected
things, some of which will be tragically weird.
And some of us, maybe even some of us in this
room, will be sporting
those at various events and being reviled
by our friends and family for
how extremely nerdy they are making us look.
Nonetheless, there are huge transformations
ahead in the meaningfulness
and the functionality of very common devices
in our lives.
I think, if you think back to the emergence
of a standard electrical
grid in our parents' lives and our grandparents'
lives, and what that
did, it transformed coffee pots that sat on
a stovetop into
percolators.
It transformed brooms into vacuum cleaners
that we could push.
It transformed wind-up clocks into wristwatches.
The world was completely transformed by the
availability of pervasive,
inexpensive electricity.
And the tools of the our lives were transformed
because electricity
came to the device in the form of a motor
and made that thing more
useful to us.
So there is a connected piano, Yamaha makes
it.
It's a Wi-Fi enabled, and it can download
music.
What I want is the model that has a Kindle-type
display where the music
stand is so that I can get sheet music to
appear in real time for me to
play.
Why not, right?
That would make the piano more "piano-ish.",
right?
That doesn't mean that I necessarily want
to scan Bloomberg headlines while I'm sitting
at the keyboard but I would like to have all
of my music available in the same format that
I may soon consume my books.
Finally, one of the coolest new connected
devices that I have because I
think it's an important milestone for us to
think about, and I leave
you with this thought as Googlers is this
is a Chumby.
It's a $99 device that has now replaced the
clock radio on my bedside
nightstand.
And it's not a browser interface.
It's a passive device that can be programmed
from a browser on your
computer to have widgets, and it can stream
my Flickr photos, and my
Twitter feed.
And it can be an alarm clock, and I can wake
up to Pandora channels that
I've designed.
And it has -- not a computer experience; it's
not a browser mindset
for -- for it's utility.
But it's bringing the Internet to me in a
brand new way.
All of these devices, I think, are examples
of ways in which our world
will become more intelligent with pervasive
connectivity and the
opportunities that you have as Googlers to
organize that information
and to deal with the new paths to consumers,
and the new devices in our
lives is just tremendous.
So I was delighted to have the invitation
to tell you a little bit
about the book.
I hope you read it.
If you read it and you like it, I'd be so
flattered if you'd put some
comments on Amazon or elsewhere, so other
people can see it.
If you don't like it, you can do that, too,
but my mother won't like
you nearly as much.
So I appreciate your time.
And happy to field some questions if you have
time and appetite.
Comments?
Questions?
>> Well, a comment first brought up by the
piano reference.
There are two ways that a company like Google
can advance things. And
one is to spill into a solutions base that
is vacant and another one is
to batter down the very thick, very high walls
of copyright, is one of
those very thick, very high walls standing
in the way of things like
what you describe because --
Emily Nagle Green: Yeah, I know I'd like to
have --
>> Yeah, it's very hard to deal with an industry
that's used to paper
reproduction and get the deals with all of
the enormous number of
different copyright owners to be able to do
something like that.
And while Google has taken on very big challenges
like that, when
you're talking about a huge explosion of opportunities,
really the
spilling into the open spaces is probably
where -- where we have to
start before we can start trying to adjust
copyright law to -- to deal
better with sheet music.
Emily Nagle Green: Yeah.
Yeah.
I completely take your point, and I'm sure
you're right about -- about
that.
What I think over the long term is, I think
maybe our kids or maybe
some of you, will ultimately look back and
the -- what seems now like
the conventional outlook on intellectual property,
I think will
ultimately look quite quaint.
And I think it will look like a blip in the
long path of human
civilization that for, you know, maybe half
a century, we thought that
there had to be a choke hold on people's creations,
their words, their
music.
Because it wasn't the case in the Middle Ages.
You know, there was no sense of ownership
of things.
And I think we're moving to a new model that's
going to look more like
that.
But you're right, in the meantime, there is
a transition because
there's an incredible intransigence of the
established economy around
ownership and the revenues associated with
that.
But nonetheless, it's definitely going to
change.
Just how long it's going to take, and aren't
there really interesting
things for Google to do in the meantime is
probably the question.
Yeah?
You should take the mic.
>> Yeah, I had a question.
Emily Nagle Green: Yeah, okay.
Go for it.
>> So I had a quick question about the map
that put up earlier, and the
different kind of Anywhere countries that
you thought would materialize
by 2013, and they were like clearly all developed
and already very
wealthy countries.
And what do you think this kind of explosion
of technology and
connectivity within these already wealthy
and like very privileged
countries, like what kind of bearing would
that have in like the
relative development of developing countries?
Because I think this will provide a great
amount of opportunity for
people who are already connected but for countries
who are not even --
not even close to that like how will that
match up?
Like, do you have like a sense of what that
will be?
Emily Nagle Green: I understand what you're
asking, I think.
I actually think that it -- at the end of
the day, if we would be able
to measure the individual benefits that come
from the explosion of a
ubiquitous global network, it will be greater
for individuals,
ultimately, outside what we now think of as
the developed regions.
And the reason is that while they may not
have in ten-years time, they
may not have a network, a sense of abundance
that's as squanderable as
we will have.
They may not have been fiber to the home,
and they may not have 4G or
5G or 6G, they will have the first digital
infrastructure they've ever had.
And where the digital infrastructure that
we have here is evolving, it
supplements existing infrastructure.
I could still get a newspaper on my doorstep
every day until the Boston
Globe gives up the ghost, right?
And I still have banks that I can go to, I
have brick and mortar stores
that I can go to.
So if the Internet melted down tomorrow, I
would be very sad but I
wouldn't be unable to get on with my life.
I could go to stores and do my banking and
get my news.
But where the network is emerging, even in
a more limited form, and
wireless networks through very limited feature
phones or maybe the very
cheap smartphones, I hope, that's the first
time people are having
access to information, banking, connecting
them to the health care
environment.
So their experience might not be something
that's going to support the
evolution of four dimensional smell-o-vision
or whatever you guys
invent next.
It's going to be more life-changing for them
cause it's going to give
them their first ever opportunity to participate
in a larger economy.
So I think ultimately the innovations that
will come from getting the
next, you know, 3 or 4 billion people connected
to the network those
innovations might be more meaningful to all
of us in society.
And I think the sources of innovation may
shift from thinking of them
as Silicon Valley and Cambridge and Western
Europe, and the sources of
innovation might actually be those places
that are desperate to have
the advantages that they don't have today
like India, where incredibly
creative things are getting done right now
with very cheap phones and very limited wireless
networks.
I don't know if that answers your question.
>> So I'd be interested to find out, like,
what you see is happening
with the transfer-open Internet, cause I feel
like a lot of these
forecasts assume that the network will stay
open and it's not going to
be throttled and cross-associated with -- so
as a prognosticator, what
do you see happening in the next couple years
with that?
Emily Nagle Green: It's a good question, and
I will say that there's
an entire chapter in the book that deals with
what I would call black
swans, which are things that could threaten
the assumptions that we
make at Yankee Group about this happy future.
There's no question that regulation and other
legislative constraints
could threaten some of the assumptions we
make.
And one of which is that the Internet will
-- or that the larger
network will be an open place.
So we do go into some detail to acknowledge
those, because while it's a
convenience to make certain assumptions, it's
not fair to go forward
without saying, gee, there are some substantial
threats.
Net neutrality in the US and elsewhere is
a really, really big issue.
I'm very concerned that it plays out in a
way that's fair to the people
that build networks and fair to the people
that want to use networks.
It's on a better path right now, today, than
it was 6 months ago,
maybe, or two years ago.
But that's a threat.
Maybe not getting enough of the network built
out is a threat, if
mobile operators don't make swift and steady
moves toward 4G
technologies, that drag their feet for whatever
reason.
That's a threat.
There are a lot of things that could make
our picture a little less
happy in the future than I what I described.
Do you have a comment?
>> I have a question.
So most of us are here today not because we
don't have computers with
network access at home, but in order to have
in-person interactions
with the other people here, right?
And people are kind of fundamentally social
in an in-person way, and I
wanted to ask how you see that interacting
with the increased data
access anywhere?
Emily Nagle Green: Yeah, well I think back
to my concept,
I'm waiting for somebody to invent four dimensional
smell-o-vision.
I mean, that's my standard joke that, you
know, as long as there's
squanderable abundance in the network, someone
will come up with
something cool to do whether it's shipping
x-rays to India so they can
be examined by less expensive medical staff
overnight, or, you know,
creating something like YouTube.
I had a very, very early video conferencing
system years ago when I
lived abroad and I led a group of people in
Europe.
And we had one of those very early systems,
and I was absolutely dogged
in my insistence that the company use it and
that everybody be trained
on it.
And it was stunningly difficult and painful
experience for all of us.
And when I finally relented over my insistence
that we use it,
everybody in the company took a huge sigh
of relief.
Okay, Emily is not going to be a, you know,
video conferencing-manic
person anymore.
But tele-presence experiences through things
like the Cisco system that
a lot of people have experience with now are
already dramatically
different than those early experiences.
You can read the notes that people are taking
on another site.
You can see the sweat on somebody's brow.
So even for things as important as face-to-face
job interviews, they
are proving to be reasonable substitute, a
substitute.
I think you look at what's happening there,
and you look at what's
happening in my old field, which is special
effects in the
entertainment business, and you look at the
maturation of that
technology as evidenced by Avatar, you know,
3-D and motion capture,
that makes the things that I worked on 20
years ago look
extraordinarily primitive.
So that's a long way of saying that while
none of those experiences are
really a substitute for being in this room
-- and apologies to the DVR
participants -- I do think the substitutes
for being in face-to-face
experience are going to gradually get better.
I don't know if that -- do you agree?
>> I certainly agree they're getting better.
I remain undecided as to whether I think they
will ever become good
enough that they're seen as an essentially
perfect substitute or
whether there's something about being there
in person some, some
ineffable something that people will always
value.
Emily Nagle Green: Yeah.
You might be right.
Comment?
>> Yeah, just a question about when you talk
about the squanderable
resource, I'm reminded of a comment that the,
you know, the high honcho
at AT&T made and then immediately regretted
about how, you know, 80
percent of their network bandwidth was being
used by like one or two
percent of their users and maybe we'll have
to go by pay by the
megabyte pricing.
And certainly, at certain places, we take
for granted that Wi-Fi is
available everywhere but you step outside
of the high tech arena, and
you know, it's not.
And I'm sort of curious, you know, especially
we do something like 4-D
smell-o-vision, it's going to take a lot of
bandwidth.
And there seems to be this hidden assumption
that a lot of us make, that
eventually, we don't have to worry about bandwidth
or availability
everywhere, that the model is pay 40 to 100
bucks a month, and you get
all you can drink.
And do you believe that's a fair assumption,
and if not, what might
have to change?
Emily Nagle Green: Well, the electrical industry
has been through
this, right?
And we don't -- none of us believe that electricity
should be free to
everyone, I don't think, if we took a poll.
However, we do expect it to be everywhere,
and we do expect its cost to
be minimal, and we expect other people to
bear the cost for us in
places like airports and what not.
We don't expect to have to pay directly for
electricity.
And as much as the network operators who make
up, to be honest, a large
portion of my client base, so it's tough to
-- it's tough to say this
-- but, you know, one of the jobs of being
an analyst is to speak truth
to power.
It's tough for them to hear that analogy because
they don't like the
idea that they will be as uninteresting and
as un-central to our future
as a utility provider is, because that's just
not really a sexy
business to be in.
And they want to be, you know, a much more
central player in that
world.
But I think we are moving towards a world
where connectivity, in order
to be pervasive and in order to do all the
things we want it to do we
will really demand economy in the provision
of that.
But the problem that we have in the -- in
the progression towards that
future is that we have a bunch of businesses
who are used to having a
subscription relationship with you.
And so they, they're having to let go of the
idea that every device
that you add isn't an opportunity for another
bill to your house.
And they're having trouble thinking about
how their business models can
shift to be very different than what they
are today.
And the -- the near term thing that frustrates
me the most some days is
that they're having a hard time moving towards
different ways of
charging you for providing the service.
I think a lot of us would be okay with the
more of something you
consume, the more you should pay.
I don't think any of us think that's an unfair
economic principle, but
one of the problems with implementing it is
that a lot of consumers
don't understand what is a megabyte or a gigabyte.
That's a bewildering unit of measurement.
So, you know, why shouldn't they be charging
me for, you know downloading 20 songs or you
know what I song is.
I have a sense of that entity.
And their move towards charging models that
are simple for consumers to
understand and would allow them to feel less
victimized by our
consumption.
They're moving in that direction very slowly.
And I think that's a problem for them.
And they may suffer the consequences of that
slow move.
But it's in their hands.
>> [inaudible]
Emily Nagle Green: Oh, I would love to.
I thank you for the invitation.
I was going to say one thing that, in closing.
The very last page of the book -- I think,
I'm going to grab a copy and
read it.
As I recall, it's the last or the next to
the last page of the book,
there's a line in here.
I told you I met Steve Vinter last year, and
I was almost finished with
the writing of the book.
And on page 250, on the bottom it says, "I
met an executive recently
who happened to mention that he left his old
job for a new position at
Google because it offered him a chance to
change the world."
That was Steve, and it stuck in my mind.
And I thought what a marvelous source of inspiration.
And so I applaud you for all of you trying
to change the world, and I
think the network that's emerging is going
to help a lot of other
people to change the world as well.
Thanks for your attention.
Thanks.
[applause]